todos estos motociclistas son veteranos
del ejército estadounidense algunos
sirvieron 20 años otros menos son
hermanos de armas pero cambiaron el
uniforme por las carreteras de virginia
este es james un ex infante de marina
con cuatro misiones en afganistán
y este es one un desminador que fue
gravemente herido en kapisa forman parte
de los más de 800.000 soldados
estadounidenses que fueron desplegados
en afganistán en los últimos 20 años
andar por las carreteras juntos les
permite mantener la camaradería que
vivieron en el ejército
[Música]
desde el anuncio en abril de la retirada
completa de las tropas estadounidenses
de afganistán los talibanes han retomado
kabul y casi todo el país
para james retirarse no fue la decisión
correcta y teme el regreso del
terrorismo
yo creo que el trabajo se termine nunca
y eso me preocupa dice este trabajo
durante los últimos 20 años para evitar
que el terrorismo se extendiera por
ahora el miedo que se extienda por todo
el país e incluso más allá de las
fronteras
james ya estaba en el ejército en el
momento de los ataques terroristas del
11 de septiembre de 2001 como muchos
estadounidenses de su generación esta
tragedia marcó su vida así que para él
esta guerra era necesario no teníamos
otra opción que ir si no lo hubiéramos
hecho habría sido peor
después del 11 de septiembre no
hubiéramos actuado quién sabe qué habría
pasado
podemos evitarlo todo no perdí amigos
perdí infantes de marina
pero todos sabíamos en que nos metíamos
nivel de sacrificios
desearía que siguieran con nosotros por
supuesto que sí me pregunto a diario
porque ellos y no yo si constantemente
más de dos mil 370 soldados murieron en
afganistán desde que comenzó la guerra
en 2001
es una coaster mother madre de uno de
los muertos en combate su único hijo
plate era sargento de la división 82
aerotransportada
decidió que quería entrar al ejército
cuando estaba en el colegio un día vino
a verme y me dijo fui a hablar con el
reclutador
luego eligió la infantería y recuerdo
que pensé
no porque infantería los soldados de
infantería son los soldados de a pie del
ejército están en primera línea de
batalla y por tanto más expuestos en
esta habitación donde clay creció todo
está intacto y meticulosamente
conservado
se ven muy guapos con sus botas de color
burdeos y se ven tan orgullosos me
gustaba verlo con el uniforme
clay fue asesinado en 2009 durante un
despliegue en un puesto avanzado en la
región de paktika en la frontera con
pakistán patrullaba con miembros de su
batallón cuando su vehículo voló a causa
de un artefacto explosivo improvisado
tenía 29 años para su madre es difícil
encontrarle sentido al conflicto de dos
décadas y conozco mucha gente que está
enfadada
las opiniones están divididas
nadie hubiera imaginado que esto duraría
tanto tiempo veinte años
y todas esas muertas
a menudo me dijo que nunca imaginé que
el 11 de septiembre acabaría matando mi
o
play está enterrado en el cementerio
militar de fort james cerca de san
antonio su madre lo visita varias veces
al año a pesar del dolor siente que su
hijo cumplió con su deber
no creo que haya muerto por nada así son
las cosas hicimos lo que teníamos que
hacer cuando fuimos a la guerra siempre
me dijeron que teníamos que luchar
nuestra la verdad y eso es lo único que
sea usted pagó el precio más alto por su
país
si bien lo pago así como todos son seres
queridos
según las últimas encuestas la mayoría
de los estadounidenses apoya la retirada
de las fuerzas de afganistán en
washington los parlamentarios están
preocupados por el destino de los
supletorios afganos que no pudieron ser
repatriados así como por los ciudadanos
estadounidenses que decidieron quedarse
eeuu debatirá esta guerra
es nuestra guerra más larga y hablar en
adelante décadas de nuestros errores y
nuestro sexo
wang pero lo que sí sabemos con certeza
es que los próximos meses tenemos la
oportunidad de encontrar algo de honor y
hacer lo correcto apoyando a aquellos
cuyo servicio y me adaptado a nuestro
país no pueden ser cuestionarios
standing band
el diputado demócrata jason crowe afirma
que la retirada de afganistán era
inevitable era demasiado pronto para
salir no yo apoyé la decisión del
gobierno de retirarse estuvimos en
guerra durante 20 años fui dos veces
como combatiente subieron a su misión
militar este conflicto la habríamos
encontrado hace mucho tiempo
las evacuaciones militares en kabul
terminaron el pasado 31 de agosto más de
200.000 afganos con derecho de asilo
seguirían atrapados en afganistán para
protegerlos la diplomacia estadounidense
no tiene otra opción que mantener el
diálogo con sus antiguos enemigos